tell us about the talent search for
Space Command and using the Kickstarter
backers and she will be yeah well
Kickstarter I mean think clean on Space
Command is I'm going to be making a
series of films and it's a big epic
story takes place over two hundred years
in our future exploration of the solar
system and out into the Stars it's
basically about two families the camera
family in the sikandar family and we go
over several generations with them as
all these amazing things happen in our
future so it's lots of special effects
big canvas epic story and we're jumping
at various points some of our stories
are very far down that time line
somewhere closer to our own time and
it's not so it's not a linear chronology
it's very much and so there's going to a
lot of roles and so I'm casting a lot of
my friends armin shimerman from deep
space nine I worked on deep space 9 a
lot of other shows even Phillips who
played Neelix in Star Trek Voyager and
amber Benson from buffy and doug jones
from pans labyrinth and Hellboy these
are all people that you know i'm writing
roles for their playing aliens and
androids and all sorts of stuff and but
I also you know I was thinking about it
I was thinking about Kickstarter is very
much the public the audience the fans
are every bit as much of this creative
process as we are and it's a very much a
two-way street and I'm not I'm not
arrogant about that at all i'm not i'm
not the big guy on the on the tiller the
dispensing wisdom you know that's not
that's not my role I it's too it's a
it's a two-way conversation I'm
enormously grateful whether someone
gives me five thousand dollars or a
dollar thank you you know it earned that
money or inherited or why they get to
get that money somewhere I'm grateful so
I thought I was thinking about I think
okay let's this is participatory and
we've been getting affects people
contacting us and makeup people and I
thought well how can I make it as
participatory as possible and there were
two roles that I hadn't yet cast I
hadn't really plugged any of my friends
in on those roles and I thought okay one
of them is the lead commander Matt
kimmer of the spaceship paladin and and
there was a young member of the crew
cadet Bradbury and I actually named that
that character from the beginning it was
way before they passed away but because
this is this is so inspired by Ray
Bradbury's work in Heinlein and asthma
see Clark for a particularly ray I name
the character cadet Bradbury and anti
decide when we have anyone in the world
can audition for these roles we can go
on the Space Command website they can
pull down scenes that we call them sides
to audition with and they can just put a
video on youtube it doesn't have to have
the you know like a movie it can just be
they're auditioning and they can put
them you to buy me and our backers on
Kickstarter on Space Command can vote
and we'll narrow it down to five each
and well you know and then we'll have
second round and it's just kind of like
and also another thing I'm going to be
doing this certain actress and well what
about us we're not we don't fit either
of those roles so I'm actually gonna
write scenes for a character called
other and then people will be able to
audition for that role to where it's
like anybody any size any age any race
any anything they can audition for that
if they don't suit through and and also
i'm a cadet bradbury non-gender-specific
so it can be a male it can give female
because again i thought that's fun
that's interesting and because i'm very
inclusive and I and I recognize that
then that wonderful brilliant person
well for instance buying to the Star
Trek episode a world left in time I cast
a lead actress from a very successful
show and she was very very good and in
four weeks before we were going to shoot
this is after six months of building the
team she sat down with me said I just
until I have to have surgery I cannot do
this role and I went white and that's
again why it's where he would have a
wife because the lane said don't worry
we'll have auditions and someone better
will come in through that door and there
was an actress named Christina Moses
would never done television never done
Philip she only done stay
she done stage in New York and she came
in and she auditioned for the role cast
her in the lead opposite George Takei
playing George's daughter and she was
the best actress I ever worked with
she's phenomenal and and she's so good
that for two years I was banging on JJ
Abrams saying you got to check this
after shot you gotta watch this episode
finally he emailed me said you were two
years ahead of us you're absolutely
right he put it on a talent deal and she
was auditioning for the leads in his
shows so that's how amazing that was and
she and I cast her in the lead in Space
Command too so so knowing that someone
with no TV or film credits could be the
most phenomenal actress I've ever worked
with I learned one thing I try to do is
learn from what happens in my life so I
learned that lesson and that's how the
Talent Search came about and so I'm
thrilled with what's going to happen you
know it's gonna be you know and when you
talk about that big break in that fairy
godmother moment you know those don't
often happen but sometimes they do and
and when they happen it isn't just the
the unknown person where it's a great
gift to them it's great gift to us
because we get the gift of their talent
you know themselves where they are
you